Christian Andrew what are your plans for
tonight
he's going home for the first time in
three months Andrew Tate his brother
Tristan and two Romanian women have all
been held in custody and Bucharest
repeatedly denied bail since being
arrested in December on suspicion of
human trafficking rape and forming an
organized crime group authorities think
the gang used what's called a Loverboy
technique to entrap women into thinking
they were in relationships before
controlling them and forcing them to
engage in pornographic acts for profit
thank you
they deny all allegations and have still
not been charged and tonight the court
of appeal in Romania has let them go to
be held instead under house arrest
they have kept the spirit definitely and
I believe they're really again they're
really thrilled I don't think there's
anything else on their mind right now
other than just going home
and being able to be home have a
home-cooked meal and be you know just a
bit more normal again the 36 year old
was a former kickboxer who became huge
on social media in recent years for his
mix of misogynistic views so end up with
all these chicks just stuck in their
house sitting there bored completely in
love with me and of course they don't go
out they're not allowed out and lavish
lifestyle campaigners though warn he's
having a damaging impact on the young
boys who follow and idolize him what has
perhaps fed into his success if we can
call it success
um are still there pornography
um kind of a veneration of material
wealth well particularly this kind of
misogynistic
uh Trend that's really really Gathering
Pace
um around the world
he might be leaving prison tonight but
he's not a free man and still very much
under investigation by the Romanian
authorities
Rachel venables Sky News